because we knew you in this country as
an actress then you went to Hollywood
and we saw you quite which seemed at the
time sort of surprising films like you
showed up in jr. with on a porch snicker
which is fun actually
what's that fun to do he was really he
was actually orange Arnold was really
truly orange I believe there are a lot
of them about here now right there's I
mean how but he was very nice was very
quickly
no way Austrian and sort of caught Liam
yes come here
no no
listen one you film saving mr. banks
I've seen it it's just brilliant oh it
is so good thank you very much it opens
next Friday the 29th of November yes now
you're playing at P L Travers
yeah look Mary Poppins Tom Hanks plays
yeah they've got a picture of the two of
you at a premiere there you are oh yeah
the kids for the banana down just saw
these until they would be good props for
later yeah you keep them there they go
lovely
you look scary like a woman I had a
one-night stand with him Wigan yeah do
you do one line after the other do you
all do all one and then go back to the
other one when I do a table read yeah I
have to jump back and forth right okay
how much going on hello sad man doing
away